[Music]
[Applause]
the book is swimming with the blowfish
hoodie healing and one hell of a ride
jim sonifeld hoodie and the blowfish
drummer songwriter
the book comes out next month and
sony joins us on the program
why write a book
i was feeling dangerous
i uh
honestly i think
being an old guy i wanted to see if
there was something meaningful in my
life
and i thought there was that i could
share that might help some other people
maybe help them understand
the trials and tribulations and glories
and victories of being in a big rock
band but more so to tell about
how i got to that place
how my bandmates to some degree got to
that place and and that also sort of
exposed some of the the downfalls that
can happen in that life of entertainment
which i which i personally fell into in
a deep way but
uh
i got lucky too the the story if you
will
has a nice ending it has a nice it was
wrapped up in a nice bow by the fact
that we got to have a huge reunion tour
in 2019
to affirm
uh
yeah that there were people out there
that still had some love for hoodie
when did you know you were in trouble
i had a chance
to accept what was
troublesome in the early
heard a few uh crew members
some guys which you know personally they
were behind a curtain they didn't know i
was on the other side of the curtain and
they were talking about someone
that they were worried about
uh this guy's partying really hard he's
prone to some uh
temperament he's has these violent
outbursts where he's hanging out with
weird people and i literally thought
huh i need to find out who they're
talking about because i'm one of the
four bosses here i employ all these
people
and i
got close to that curtain when they said
yeah we just don't know who's going to
be the one that's going to have to talk
to sony about his problem
and i was devastated i literally
could not believe they were talking
about me the worry the anxiety was about
me they were worried and so what did i
do i had all the information i needed to
say
man this is great you guys are right my
life is careening out of control but no
i'm a real addict i dove into
i need to hide it better i need to
figure a way out that they're not going
to be worried and uh
but still do my drinking still do my
drugs still hang out with whoever i
wanted to so that was my chance i
suffered for about four more years after
that before i came to reality
but you don't know what you're looking
for you know those on the outside i
didn't know like you hit it pretty well
and i was around the band for a long
time a lot of those
tour stops
and i remember one time in boston and i
said to
mark the lead guitar player and then
darius the lead singer i said where's
sony and they go back in his room
and i never under i didn't know what
that meant i thought oh we're good for
him like he's not at the bar i thought
maybe you're just boring
and then i i remember pressing those
guys a little bit and they say no he
goes back there and he drinks out of the
mini bar
was that accurate
absolutely
when
someone who's sick in the thinking i was
and the actions i was if there wasn't
people to participate with me if i
couldn't get the circus
uh revved up around me
or i didn't like what it looked like
because i was doing things that i wasn't
supposed to be doing
there's always a hotel room there's
always
isolation and uh you know i had the
the either benefit or curse i don't know
how you look at it but
i could be the crazy guy in boston or
the isolated guy
because the fact is
in 24 hours i was going to be in a
different town usa and then another town
and then another town so my worries or
my
path of carnage i was able to leave it
behind night after night after night
thinking i had escaped any consequences
until
they all caught up with me but also you
at some point do you embrace the
lifestyle or does the lifestyle embrace
you or maybe it starts out that you
embrace it then it you realize that it's
got the hold on you not the other way
around
i was very flexible dan
[Laughter]
i was willing to wear different masks i
was willing to
do anything to you know
fall into the lifestyle or
fall away from it if i could
successfully do what i wanted to do
which was mainly get a drink up to my
mouth or find something to help me stay
awake to get to drink longer and so yeah
i mean
camouflage is an alcoholics sort of uh
trick and so if i could camouflage
become slightly different for different
people
i would do that very unhealthy though in
the end did you drink
were you drunk on stage
i never entered drunk and i you know
again
an addict or someone that suffers in in
the way i do
we're not
necessarily stupid or or uh even misled
uh or we don't it's not like we lack
self-will
i'll do whatever i can to to succeed in
in not getting caught but getting what i
need so no enter the stage like you've
done with us before shot a yeager shot a
beam
you get on there clean it's a lot of
focus it's a lot of you want to be clean
uh and that just began that was like my
my ramp into
oblivion so by the end of the show i'd
have a good buzz going but
what looks better from the audience than
a bunch of guys that are out there
really letting it letting it go sweating
having fun doesn't look scripted and
ours was never scripted
you know that's that's a good way to do
two hours
and as the son of an alcoholic
i know that you guys are very good at
hiding things or at least you think you
are until you're not and then everybody
notices what you think they're not
noticing
i just wonder like the interventions
how many times did people try to kind of
grab you and say dude
you know you're giving it all away
oh goodness
there's nothing worse than than having
an intervention even by people that love
you there's uh when you feel the walls
closing in and you know the talk is
coming
your squirm you know
and for the last few years i knew
uh as my consequences became a little
more public at least in our group i knew
they were coming and
most of them i think done with love
but deny deny deny is sort of the game
i'm okay or i'm working on that and the
book tells as much how different band
members
in their love and worry uh spoke to me
and it was it wasn't until my last
intervention that came from a little bit
of a place i wasn't expecting that
actually made me think a little deeply
and i was sober a month later
wildest bands you tur toured with
you know the
not that i even saw them in action but i
saw the results of their actions and it
was van halen
because
we got on this
crazy tour that a couple festivals in
germany we were the only not
hard rock band and we were of course it
was a big 10 hour festival we were
probably the second band playing to a
few people in munich stadium
hey it's like 90 empty
hands
so
we get we share a big backstage with all
these other hard rock bands including
van halen and i'm thrilled this is my
entrance into hard rock with van halen
in high school so
i see them in their trailer and here's
eddie walking out from his trailer
and he's a little gimpy
and he's a little slow i'm like what's
up with him and he gets to the bottom
and he out comes a cane i'm like whoa
that's not good he's got a cane
right behind him is alex his brother the
drummer a hero of mine
and he's
looking this way when he gets out and
then he looks this way i'm like why is
he
physically looking so weird he gets
closer he's got a huge neck brace so
here's like two guys looking like they
just walked out of a
war zone and they're supposed to be my
heavy metal heroes i'm like
is that what i'm in for is that where
i'm going because this was only the mid
to late 90s i was still
partying without as many consequences
but i thought if that's the end game
here i gotta get some new health
insurance
also when they think of hooting the
blowfish they always think what you guys
are just nice guys and never part when i
would tell people i said those guys can
get after it they're like no they can't
like what do you guys have like light
beer or something i go
no i i don't think so i think there's
some other things going on here
i mean you're not motley crew but you
know
felt like you guys got after it um
maybe more than you know
america thought
nice guys can get out of control too and
nice guys can
live out on the edge and even have some
consequences i don't know honestly how
we escaped
the headlines we were probably a little
lucky if anything that way where some of
our actions didn't end up on the front
page or uh there wasn't a bust-up
or anything happening it's a little
lucky honestly we pre predated cell
phones so there wasn't a bunch of people
at night taking pictures backstage that
would have been a whole different story
so we're a little lucky if anything he's
jim sonefeld the drummer for hooting the
blowfish the book comes out next month
swimming with the blowfish hoodie
healing in one hell of a ride
um what do you remember the day you
became famous
the band my mind
oh you know
the day i had an inkling that things
were happening was probably sitting on
the stage
late night with david letterman it was a
place where i said
oh wait we're being beamed into the
living rooms of millions of people
with our little song hold my hand
this is
and i was nervy i saw the red lights
saying record coming on and i was and i
talked about this in the book
to be sitting on that stage where the
beatles sat
in the year of my birth 1964 was like
stupendous and i sense like this is
this could take us to a place we've
never ever gone
um
and it did that was that was the turn
where uh you go from playing clubs and
theaters to
millions of homes you can't deny as you
like to say you can't deny us
and it worked they liked the song
radio stations played it people
supported us we did great videos thank
you dan
and
yeah and and sony road to hold my hand
just to let everybody know i mean
you did change the lives of those guys
and without that song
i don't there might be hootie in the
blowfish but there wouldn't be
hootie in the blowfish
worldwide
it's always it's always good to come
into a
audition for a band with something in
your back pocket i'm not going to arrive
empty-handed so i had been writing songs
for a few years none of it worth
anything i was the king of writing songs
that weren't great that weren't working
that weren't catchy until one day it was
with three chords and yeah i arrived to
my audition with the band
uh sort of here's this here's this tune
what do you guys think meekly i wasn't
trying to play him but i honestly hadn't
played it for anybody else so i didn't
know if it was uh going to be a great
song and they
they looked at each other like okay you
can stay
um and you you found somebody uh who
helped you here uh
so the former wife of
lead guitar player mark
is your wife
and
i like i i was never bored when i was
around you guys they'd go oh you know
what's happening now and i go what and
then it'd be you know this over here
this over here this over i go wait wait
sony is dating mark's why xy yeah yeah
and i remember talking to you about it
go yeah it's cool it's cool but
she helped save you and maybe vice versa
through all of this
well
certainly i mean we we
may look normal on the outside but if
you ever look behind the curtain you
know dan you stood at my first wedding
and
the twists that come are not always in
the headlines but there's nothing
weirder than
what we've managed to do with my uh
and laura's marriage 14 years now
to be successful as parents all of us
exes and laura and i with five kids it's
it's been a victory but uh one nobody
saw coming uh yeah certainly it's a
great twist for the book to see an
ending uh that is you never see coming
laura in fact was the one i talked about
my last intervention being the one that
was the only one that made me think and
it was laura then laura brian that gave
me that intervention it's because she
came to it from a way that she wasn't
demanding answers she wasn't
doing what a lot of interventions end up
doing which is telling me how bad my
actions are
how i got to get my junk together how i
am disappointing so many people i knew
that but she asked it in a different way
saying do you value yourself
do you want something better for you in
your life and your family
and she
after that intervention
uh i walked away thinking and it took me
about
30 or 40 more drunks to go i do value my
life in fact if i don't start value
valuing it with an action i'm going to
be dead in a few weeks because my
alcohol and drug intake was very high i
just happened to be playing it off
better than the most the average
alcoholic
it's pretty amazing
i mentioned this earlier in the show
that i've known you so long but i didn't
really know you
until probably the last two years i feel
like i i know you now whereas before you
were just the drummer in the band
and i just always had a good time every
time i saw you but i don't know if i
ever invested in you
because i don't know if you allowed
people to invest in you because you kind
of had that mask on
when it gets dark
and my life was getting dark due to my
uh substance abuse
you're in the dark
i'm not wanting to shine for other
people i want to be isolated and i
became
isolated and yeah it was a different
thing from when we were first hanging
out
you know playing basketball backstage as
young men
probably in our
30s
uh
you know shirts off and
and there wasn't a worry in the world
you know that's if you fast forward
let's see whatever that was 95
to 2005 there's
there's what 10 years can do to change
your life and and i look back with
fondness on the whole trip obviously the
book
talks about the darkness but i also
wanted to celebrate the joy the fact
that
though we worked hard we never could
have seen what was coming ahead of time
and our lives changed and our children's
lives changed as well uh forever so uh
and i remember when we were in glasgow
because i went to london scotland uh
ireland
and uh
it was underground
i don't know how many people there a
couple of thousand
yeah but uh sony would always take his
shirt off when he was drumming and then
i made sure i caught his attention on
the side of the stage and i had my shirt
off with my my white khakis
and uh
had some good times
you know where where were the video
cameras that was my 40th birthday and my
wife said yes go on tour with hoodie and
the blowfish
well then you're a lot older than i
thought dan yes i am yeah no you look a
lot older than i do but you've done more
damage to your body sony
you ought to see the inside
no that's not pretty
um good luck with the book and uh
hopefully we'll see you guys back on on
the road one of these days sony has a
latest single called it's good to get
back where's that available
spotify or any of your streaming
channels uh check it out it's good old
rock and roll thank you buddy
god bless you that's sony uh jim
sonifeld hooting the blowfish swimming
with the blowfish hootie healing and one
hell of a ride comes out next month